[Applause]
protests against zimbabwe's government
are rare here doctors and nurses in the
public health sector know they are
taking a huge risk in the past some
workers have been victimized or fired
for speaking out about working
conditions and salaries
but these people are growing
increasingly desperate and say their
wages are being eroded by rising
inflation
this is an act of last resort we ask the
public to hold the government
accountable for how they are treating
health workers but more importantly how
they are treating just the general civil
service it's common knowledge that the
currency is imperial but they have not
taken action most of the people you see
here don't own houses
it's the second workout by health
workers during the covert 19 pandemic
last week unions rejected the
government's offer to double member
salaries
a 100 wage increase may sound like a lot
but inflation reached more than 130
percent in may that means it'll do
little to our people facing a rising
cost of living
[Applause]
public sector employees want their wages
paid in u.s dollars union leaders say
the lowest paid government worker takes
home less than 20 000 zimbabwe dollars a
month that's less than 100 us dollars
they want that to go up to 540 us
dollars but that may not be feasible
government then has to demonetize the
whole financial sector
convert the same dollar balances and
other savings in zim dollars
into u.s dollars so obviously that
requires a huge
amount of money which government may
actually not have
work stoppages and go slows are common
in the public health sector zimbabweans
who can't afford treatment at private
hospitals suffer people are dying
because of these sex
because
necessity
even if you are in a bad situation or in
an emergency they won't attend you
people are dying because of that
so it affects us much striking health
workers insist they won't report for
duty until their demand for more money
is met others worried about their pair
getting docked if they miss a shift say
they will be in the wards but they will
be on a goal slow hara mutasa al jazeera